foreign
Lansing Michigan what's up Rose
hi good morning
what's up
um you never hear that do you I'm sorry
all right sorry I got that out of my
system all right okay what's up okay so
tell me what's up
um oh boy okay
um wow I'm sorry my singing tends to do
that to people it's not great
I wanted to be a metal singer growing up
that's all I wanted to be in the world I
wanted to be this really tough cool
metal singer and now I'm a YouTuber so
clearly my singing is not great but alas
alright so this call is about you not
not my failed attempts to be cool so
what's up
um well I guess I'll just get to it
um
my um question is how do you move on
from
past
lots of horrible past things
and um
just change your life and
get your marriage
back to or I guess we
redo your marriage
[Music]
probably the top two or three Vegas
conversations I've ever had it's it's
incredible how do you you know that
stuff that they yeah okay so
um sorry all right here's it's one of
two things and and I'm only this is this
is just I've had this conversation so
many times either
um there's been abuse in the past like
physical or emotional abuse in the past
and y'all are still
you you are your spouse is has forgiven
the other person and you want to move on
or one or both of you have cheated on
each other and y'all want to move on
which one is it or tell me I'm wrong
um some of all of that oh geez Louise on
a stick okay so how long have y'all been
married
uh we've been married seven years okay
and tell me first about the
physical and emotional abuse
um well thankfully not system
okay
on both sides we've just
in the beginning of our marriage just
very immature and
thankfully we're coming out of that okay
but and
um when did the infidelity start
um
on his side
[Applause]
probably
I don't know maybe a year or two in
and then my side
I'd say
let's see it'd be three years ago
but that had started okay with with did
you fall for somebody or was it multiple
partners
um you just started dating around behind
his back
um one was an online thing and then a uh
physical one which was
about a year ago two years okay does he
know about it
he does yes and do you know about his
yes yeah we uh
shared it all okay how did y'all come to
how did y'all land there like that's x
marks the spot how did y'all both decide
we're just gonna put all this on the
table
what brought you there
um we asked the big question if we truly
wanted to make this work and the only
way to move forward is to share it all
was our decision okay and what was
what was the result of that hard
conversation
did you both cut did you know he'd been
cheating on you and he knew you've been
cheating on him or was it a shock to
both of you or
um um we both knew okay
yeah
okay
how long ago was that how long ago was
that conversation
hmm
uh let's say
two years ago
so what's changed in the last two years
or do you find yourself right back in
the same spot
uh
tortured by my past
your pastor has passed
random thoughts will come off of
remembering
what he's done and then remembering what
I've done and then hating myself for it
I want to um I want to for the sake of
the listener and for the sake of clarity
in this conversation and there's a point
to me doing this okay
um
I want to drill down into what you just
said Just Thoughts of
do you have images in your head that pop
in of him
um
being sexually involved with another
woman
do you have do you have moments when
you're taking a shower you're sitting by
yourself in the car scrolling Instagram
and you think of physically being with
this other guy and it makes you smile or
makes your heart beat faster and then
you feel sick about it
uh yes yeah okay
is that
is that the stuff that you thought would
be gone by now
like I yeah I'm trying to get from there
to
you have these thoughts you're y'all are
working on it you're putting your
marriage back together you're building
something new
and yet these thoughts keep popping into
your head and you thought they would be
gone by now is that what we're getting
at
uh yes though there is another
complication to store here there always
is go for it well I guess I'd say too
you can't get to them as quickly as you
can because yes like we're taking a long
time to circle the plane around the uh
The Landing Strip
true sorry no it's all good it's all
good
um so
who I cheated on my husband was
physically was my brother-in-law
and I had a child with him
here here
it's more complicated
that may be the understatement of the
day
yeah it definitely is it's been the
Vegas most understated uh so
that was your sister's husband
uh no uh that'd be my husband's sister's
husband
which they're now divorced yeah I would
I would just guess so I would guess yeah
um man that makes Thanksgiving awkward
huh
uh yeah though I mean nobody talks about
it
oh yeah
do they not see the little kid running
around
um they do
but I mean he looks enough like me I
don't know
okay the dysfunction here is
multi-leveled how can I help uh and you
said there was one more what's what's
the one more is there another one after
that
oh just the the chaos that's caused them
just the side of the family my side of
the family just that cool yeah okay so
how can I how can I help
um well I mean
just moving on forward I just
I just I feel lost at what to do
um
like should this be out in the open and
then we'd probably never go over to his
family or see any of them
um I don't know they don't know
and now
I mean I'm sure they have speculations
but your sister-in-law doesn't know that
it was you or she just doesn't tell
anybody
she just doesn't tell anyone yeah I I
don't believe that for less than half a
second
I'm sure she's told multiples yes I'm
confident that everybody knows and for
the sake of your husband everybody is
and this little baby everybody's trying
to keep the peace
and I'm guessing that this isn't the
only sideways
meth and banjo's things going on in this
family lineage and so I I don't I don't
I that doesn't strike they're probably
like well geez you know what I mean so
right
um at this point here's the deal at this
point your husband has made some
your husband chose to violate your
marriage covenant the thing you all
agreed on you said I do forever he
violated that you violated that
as a consequence of that violation now
you have another child
another marriage is destroyed okay and
I'm not gonna put that all on you and
put that on him
all of that sounds so complicated and it
feels like the smoke is so thick it's
really not
and one of my favorite things to do is
to sit down in a situation like this
with somebody when everything feels like
it's on fire and to actually unwind it
because it's not
really what you have before you is a s
is a
repeated series of small steps that's
going to be the next six months the next
one year the next five years the next 25
years of your life
and that is choosing to do the next
right thing
that is intentionally having once a week
or for for right now maybe twice or
three times a week Monday Wednesday and
Friday
30 minute check-ins with your husband
how are you how are you feeling
commitment to him
and him to you that there will be no
more secrets
that means you might have to for a
season be like man I thought about you
and so and so today and I
immediately tossed it out of my mind
um or I had a hard week just remembering
things that I've done I had a hard work
memory things that you've done it was
just tough or I looked up so and so on
social media today and I just had like a
moment of weakness and I screwed up and
I'm feeling bad about it
and he can't fix you all he can say is
thank you for sharing that and you can't
fix him and all you can say is thank you
for sharing that but we're practicing
not having Secrets anymore which just
means we're practicing telling the truth
which means we're practicing
vulnerability which means now we're
practicing how to be married
see that
right yeah and you gotta have a daily
choice to a not be naive
because you've cheated on him once and
you'll you might do it again and vice
versa and
I have to choose every time that thought
lightning bolts into my mind I have to
choose to have another thought ready to
go
and not dwell on it both the the ones
that make you want to throw up thinking
of him with another woman
and the ones that make your heart beat a
little bit faster and make the you smile
a little bit you with another guy
is that fair
that is fair you have to choose not to
entertain those and if you don't make
that choice you're just gonna be
choosing to bring fog into your marriage
on a daily basis and for everyone
listening this goes for everybody who
has romantic Partners from the Past who
um had almost affairs with that person
at work but she didn't at the last
minute right
those when we have other people that
make us feel alive and this is every
single marriage everybody I've ever met
in my life
I don't know anybody I'm not I'm not I'm
not uh excluded from this
old memories pop into your mind
feelings pop into your into your heart
like this person laughed at my jokes
this person made me feel comfortable
this person made me feel warm and my
person I'm married to my girlfriend my
boyfriend whoever doesn't make me feel
that today
so your body goes looking for it and it
remembers it and you have to have enough
discipline to say I'm not going to
get my fix from somebody from my past
I'm not going to get my fix from
somebody who's not my spouse I'm gonna
intentionally not do this
and that's hard man it's hard right
yeah definitely is
um and then you are gonna have to
balance
this violation you made right you
violated your core values and your
Covenant and you got this amazing
wonderful child Fair
fair so you're gonna have to there's
just gonna be attention there and trying
to feel like that tension doesn't exist
or pretend that tension doesn't exist is
a waste of your time and energy because
it's always going to be the best worst
thing that ever happened to you
right right
yeah how do you said it out loud you
slept with your sister-in-law's husband
that happened you did that with a period
you shouldn't have done that can we
agree on that
yes definitely and you have an amazing
young kid how old's this baby
uh he's won okay is he incredible is he
hilarious funny silly quiet who tell me
about him
he is a complete goofball good sounds
like he's falling after his mom right
because
and he runs around with his brother and
his sisters and
absolutely crazy
um we're gonna honor this little kid and
at the same time we're not going to
shroud this thing in shame
going to family events and pretending
like things didn't happen is
it
that's the curse of generations
it's the fog that hangs over every get
together it's the black smoke that
covers up I mean that is in the air of
every interaction between family members
and at some point your husband it's his
family he's got to step up and say hey
this happened this is and this is what
we're doing about it we're raising this
kid it's gonna be great do you have any
contact with the other guy
uh no he just ran off okay so you have
100 full custody
yes yep has your husband adopted this
kid
um under the law here he just
automatically became uh the full
Guardian
okay I would get with somebody and make
sure that's written down make sure
that's in some sort of paperwork so that
this other dude didn't pop back up
um okay in the future
um here's what I want you guys to to sit
down and ask and this is the new year
and this is a great time to start this
how can you encourage life in your
husband here's what I mean by that
what makes him feel alive
when you hold his hand watching a TV
show going dancing
when he's out farming or hunting I don't
know what he does or fixing stuff I
don't know who this dude is but what
makes him feel alive and how can you
contribute to that to breathing life
into his life
and vice versa how can he
give you life how can he breathe life
into your life that might be as simple
as helping around the house with with
dishes and babies and diapers and stuff
like that that could be taking you out
once a week that could be planning for a
big vacation once a year that could be
working four jobs to pay off any money
your family owes to other people because
you can't breathe it could be meeting
Monday Wednesday Friday to make sure
you're being intentional and make sure
your marriage is staying on this very
wobbly track that it's on right now
foreign
but how do how do you breathe life into
his life into his world and how does he
breathe life into your world that's the
question y'all are asking
and this is going to take both of you
taking a knee because y'all have both
been really really selfish and you've
both been really really immature and now
you got kids and now it's time to grow
up is that fair
yes yeah okay are you in
I'm in
how can I help that Journey do you have
my books and and all the gear
I I don't okay so I want you to hang on
the line I'm gonna send you a copy of
both redefining anxiety and own your
past change your future which my two
best-selling books and I'm gonna send
you both decks of questions for humans
for couples and this is just going to be
a way for you and your husband to have
conversations together I've already done
the work for you I've already asked a
question you just have to pull these
cards out when y'all are having some
some private time together not with kids
running around everywhere whether it's
gel on the front porch whether it's all
in the bedroom whether Joe out on a date
bring these cards and this is just going
to be a way to introduce Humanity
and for God's sake
don't cheat
period
and especially don't cheat with family
members
no more no more
thank you for being brave and for your
call